-Guys, right now, It's time
for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing
every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
This week, I sent out
the hashtag #MyWeirdCoworker.
I asked you to post
your funniest,
weirdest stories about people
that you've worked with.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you
for playing along.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#MyWeirdCoworker posts
from you guys.
Some of these are weird.
[ Laughter ]
They all are, but...
-I hope so.
This first one is from
@high, underscore, iamErica.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-That's funn-a-a-a-ay!
This one is from @KmSeokJen.
She says...
-Ew.
[ Laughter ]
Hot tub.
-Ew.
Ew!
-That's not funny!
[ Laughter ]
-That's kinda disgusting!
-That's disgusta!
-Ew! Get outta here!
-This is from @arrluk.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @SalmonEeena.
He said...
[ Audience exclaims ]
[ Cymbals crashing ]
-No.
They're brown socks.
-Why would you --
Why would yo--
Oh, no.
[ Audience exclaims ]
That's not funny!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's -- That's painful.
-That's sick!
[ Laughter ]
This is from at @thehicklife.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-Whoo!
Oh, boy!
You want a quickie?
-[ Chuckles nervously ]
-Oy!
Put on my socks.
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @sarahmeany.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
That's not funny.
Not funny.
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of our
favorites, go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.